The latest trailer for Infinity War has arrived​,
and it's packed with even more action than
before.
With a ton of all-new, epic moments thundering
across the screen, some less obvious details
are bound to slip through the cracks.
Here are the small details you may have missed
in the new Infinity War trailer.
Half the universe
While the first trailer had Thanos waxing
poetic about his dream of "balancing the universe,"
it was still pretty vague about just how he
intended to do that.
Now, Gamora spells out for us exactly what
he plans to do:
"He only ever had one goal: to wipe out half the
universe.
If he gets all the Infinity Stones, he can
do it with the snap of his fingers."
Longtime comics​ readers know what's up:
When Thanos assembled the full power of the
stones in the 1991 comic event Infinity Gauntlet,
his first order of business was to make half
of all life in the universe suddenly vanish
without warning.
He did this in order to impress Marvel’s
Death, who in the comics is a sexy undead
being he would very much like to smooch.
It seems our heroes will have a bit more of
an advance warning in the movie, but will
they be able to stop Thanos before his fateful
finger snap?
Loki’s betrayal
In the last few minutes of Thor: Ragnarok,
Loki deftly lifted the Tesseract from Odin’s
treasure room.
As the Asgardians journeyed into space away
from the ruins of their home, Loki and Thor
seemed to at last truly make amends.
Or did they?
The new Infinity War trailer finds the God
of Mischief seemingly ready to surrender the
Tesseract willingly.
The so-called "Space Stone" is likely what
will allow the Mad Titan to warp to Earth.
What’s Loki’s endgame?
It’s impossible to guess, considering he
has a penchant for double-, triple-, and quadruple-crosses.
"Surprise!"
New Order
The Black Order is Thanos’ elite squad of
lieutenants, charged with doing the kind of
nitty gritty dirty work he wouldn’t touch
with a ten-foot Infinity Gauntlet.
Their onscreen incarnation includes strategist
Corvus Glaive, the vicious Proxima Midnight,
the massive Cull Obsidian, and the slippery
Ebony Maw.
While we can only glimpse the assembled group
briefly in the trailer, Ebony Maw gets special
attention.
He may be in the midst of manipulating the
power of Doctor Strange to facilitate Thanos’
invasion, which is something he's done before
in the comics.
Tiny Gamora?
The two Guardians of the Galaxy movies have
built an epic backstory of family drama behind
Thanos and his daughters, Gamora and Nebula.
It’s a bitter tale of abuse, betrayal, and
attempted murder.
The new Infinity War trailer provides a surprising
moment of family bonding.
We see Thanos take a tiny green hand in his
giant purple one, as he walks with a young
girl toward an ornate archway.
It seems like a safe bet that the girl is
a young Gamora, but is this a flashback?
Maybe some weirdness via the Infinity Stones?
Thanos gets his helmet
Since his first appearance during the end
credits of The Avengers, Thanos’ look has
been tweaked, but he remains instantly recognizable.
But when the first Infinity War trailer hit,
many comic book fans were plagued with one
question: where’s his helmet?
Something about that big, bald head just felt
wrong.
Fortunately, the new trailer shows off multiple
shots that find his shiny hat firmly in place,
or freshly removed.
Where’s Hawkeye?
Marvel is touting Infinity War as “the culmination​
of the entire Marvel Cinematic Universe​​,”
providing a grand clash of as many heroes
and villains as can fit into two-and-a-half
hours of IMAX-sized action.
"I know all your names."
The new trailer includes just about all of
our leading stars, but one of the original
Avengers is still conspicuously missing.
Jeremy Renner is confirmed to be back once
more as Clint Barton, a.k.a. Hawkeye, but
none of Infinity War’s marketing has shown
even a single one of Hawkeye's mighty purple
feathers.
It would be strange if this founding member
of the cinematic Avengers didn’t have a
major role to play in this big payoff.
Directors Joe and Anthony Russo remain tight-lipped
on the subject of Clint, hinting only that
he has a “special spot” in the film.
Let's hope he actually stays alive and doesn't
get… well… shafted.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!